thank you
thank you Hannah as you'll know
Intelligence Squared is the home of
debate the classic debate for and
against format so you can imagine when
an email arrived in my inbox and said
Intelligence Squared event with mehdi
Hassan my reaction was no way there's no
way I'm going anywhere near that thank
you very much but I'm lucky to enough to
tell you that I'm not having to debate
media Sam because that is a losing
ticket believe me instead I'm just my
it's my great privilege tonight to be in
conversation with many uh he and I have
known each other a long time we're going
to do that up here for a bit about 45
minutes or so and then we're going to
open it up
to questions and perhaps something more
from all of you anyone who thinks that
they fancy their chances taking on Medi
Hassan in debate tonight could be your
moment as I said I'm not going anywhere
near that
um but you may want to so our Our Guest
this evening is you heard an
award-winning journalist and broadcaster
host of the media Hassan show which is
on both MSNBC and NBC's streaming
Network peacock his new book is this win
every argument to the art of debating
persuading and public speaking it's just
out you cannot move for interviews with
median publicity and it has already paid
off as you heard it's in the top 10.
um we will as I say open up for you to
have your chance to
put a question to Medi or if you're
feeling brave to take him on in debate
this whole debate
thing with humidity I mean are you were
and were you one of those people because
they do exist at kid at school those
kids who are sort of the debate champ
who aged 9 or 10 or 13 or 14 is in the
school debating society and honing those
skills when other kids are playing
football in the playground you were
there in doing debate prep is that you
um well first of all thank you Johnny
for doing this event and uh not deleting
the email in your inbox when it came in
thank you all for coming out tonight
this is my sixth public event uh in my
second country I did four in the US and
this is my second one in the UK but I
can honestly say this is the one I've
been looking for this is London this is
my hometown it's great to see you all
thank you so much
and for those of you who bought the book
and read the book you'll know that I say
that in every city I go to it's a good
way of connecting with the audience from
the very beginning I appreciate all of
you turning out tonight I didn't know
Johnny you had so many fans so thank you
for bringing out big crowd I appreciate
it uh to answer your question no I
wasn't that person actually I didn't
really do competitive debating and even
today I'm not that big a fan of
competitive debating my daughter does
high school debate In America which is a
big thing I find it just rule bound and
kind of artificial and I wrote the book
because I wanted to talk about the real
world and the real life debate my
debates in school were of the unorthodox
variety they were the debates that
involved me shouting out the answers to
questions arguing with teachers and then
spending much of the time in the hallway
with my parents receiving phone calls
from various teachers saying yes he
knows Leon Somebody needs to let other
people speak so that was my ex my
experience with debate was not a good
one in school and then I get to
University
and even at University I talk about in
the book I did Oxford Union debating the
most famous debate in Sydney World I was
very lucky privileged to have that
opportunity but even there I didn't do
competitive debate I did the exhibition
debating the Thursday night with
politicians with Boris Johnson and
Benazir Bhutto and the like so it was
always more unorthodox always I've
always been more interested in the real
world application yeah what did you
tackle Boris Johnson on uh the uh debate
at the time Oxford Union every year does
an annual debate this house has no
confidence in Her Majesty's government
and at the time labor was in power and I
was defending I was defending Tony Blair
how times change
um I was defending the Blair government
uh to be fair this was 1998 or something
way pretty Iraq um and Boris Johnson was
there on behalf of spectator on behalf
of the conservatives and I spent the
night mocking him uh recently a Dutch
documentary crew a little clip emerged
recently of a thinner weird sounding me
uh mocking Boris
um and I say in the clip he makes you
laugh but there's no substance so I was
prophetic stick there in my description
of Boris Johnson and then afterwards I
shamelessly went and asked him for an
internship with The Spectator which he
weirdly gave to me so it was a very
weird experience so it worked out for
you it's good that you're outing that
about yourself rather than waiting for
waiting for them the daily mail or
someone similar to do that
um so this book and you say the real
world application when I was reading it
and it's absolutely entertaining and
powerfully argued as you would expect
and very practical in its advice it
really does tell people how to win
arguments except I was thinking this is
great if you're a politician this is
fantastic if you are somebody who hosts
a Regular Show on cable news that
ordinary regular people do they really
need this how's this book relevant for
them so I did start out thinking about
kind of politicians media you know we've
talked about this for a long time about
some of the deficiencies in our media
I've been quite openly critical of the
British media the American media
especially interviews in America I don't
believe they're tough enough combative
enough uh one of the things I've done in
the US is try and bring my own style and
make it more mainstream more acceptable
and you know getting there little by
little so there is a lot of that in
there for people in our industry and for
politicians and a congressman named
rocana recently tweeted I plan to buy
the book and read it before I go on a
show so maybe I've shot myself in the
foot but no when I started writing it I
realized this is for everyone I started
doing the research behind kind of styles
of argument looking at the science
there's a lot of Science in the book
even though I'm not a science journalist
or a scientist but like some of the
things we take for granted how much
actual documented evidence there is for
it and then you realize actually no this
is applicable to a general crowd and I
didn't realize I would end up writing
such a kind of audience and I say I've
said in interviews it's it's for it's
for the lawyer in the courtroom yes with
the 12 jurors uh yes it's for the
businessmen in the boardroom trying to
feel the deal but it's anyone in school
who has to speak in front of a classroom
of a classmate it's it's someone sitting
around the dinner table with their you
know in America it's your mad Uncle at
Thanksgiving uh it's that uh it's it's
it's that not every technique in here is
for every argument people ask me
questions when should you do this when
should you do that context matters I say
in the book everything is about context
who is your audience
who are you trying to convince is it a
debate or is it a informal conversation
what are you trying to achieve when you
stand up in front of a room of people
are you trying to rhetorically destroy
the other person in YouTube fashion or
are you trying to present that might not
be so good at a family dinner I'm
thinking I mean you might want to
destroy a crazy Maga Uncle who wants to
build a wall I don't know how your
family dinners are but um I've had some
Lively family dinners some people here
will testify
um the but you know there's a difference
between as you say trying to destroy one
person in a debate on stage or just
sitting down with someone you care about
and trying to change their mind
one-on-one the book tries to take you
through different scenarios it's not all
I know the title is Win Every argument
but it's not all rhetorical destruction
I do have a whole chapter in there about
the importance of empathy about putting
your feet in the shoes of others
listening empathetically to where
someone's coming from and when I said I
was writing a chapter on listening my
wife turned to me and she laughed she
just laughed and then there was a long
pause she said seriously you're writing
a chapter on listening you're the worst
listener I said that's why I have to
write this chapter because I you know I
struggle with these things too I'm not a
perfect practitioner of everything in
the book but I'm trying to put together
a different skill set but yes I believe
it's across the board you go for a job
interview I hope this book will help you
you can try and negotiate a pay rise I
hope this book will help you trying to
convince your friend in the playground
that Liverpool is a better team than
Chelsea or man united I hope this book
will help you I'm gonna we should dive
in straight away because as I said it's
very very practical uh people are often
told in arguments to play the ball not
the player
um and to avoid ad hominem personal
attacks and you give contradictory
advice to that you say you should play
the ball and them player
um we're going to see an example of that
in a moment but just give us just to
explain why you think it's legitimate to
have a go at the person you're arguing
rather than just their argument so again
context matters I'm not saying do it
across the board willy-nilly wherever
you are just go attack someone that's
not a wise move as I say if you're
trying to convince someone one-on-one in
private who you care about makes no
sense to attack them that just makes
them defensive but as I say at the start
of the book sometimes your argument we
get so obsessed with what am I going to
say to that person that we forget that
that person might not be the important
person it might be the audience out
there that you're trying to appeal to
and in that case Bringing Down the
credibility what Aristotle called the
ethos of that person which is a key part
of argument the appeal to your own
person no credibility bringing theirs
down and yours up is an obvious thing to
do it's a no-brainer in an argument
where the audience wants to know who to
trust who to believe who to rely on so
it depends again on the context of where
you are before you kind of unleash you
know I I had I had John Bolton on my
show a while back and I knew we talked
about Iraq I wasn't going to change John
Bolton's mind on her that would be mad
but what I wanted to do was have the
audience at home see that his arguments
were poor and that he's being held to
account for the first time so in that
case you can address the person and what
I say in the book is the three types of
ad hominem attacks one is the abusive ad
hominem what Donald Trump takes to an
extreme the name calling you're ugly as
he says I'm not saying to do that don't
go call people names but for example
calling somebody a liar that's seen as
off limits in Our House of Commons you
can't say it it's unparliamentary
language I'm saying if somebody has a
history of lying and you're on a public
platform with them it is your obligation
to tell the crowd don't trust that
person they have a history of dishonesty
they have a history of deception now
that's technically an ad hominematics
not relevant to the argument but it is
relevant to how much scrutiny and Trust
the audience should put in that person
so I say it's relevant the
circumstantial ad hominem the conflict
of interest
um I don't believe in climate change
says the scientist who is funded by the
fossil fuel Lobby wouldn't you want to
reveal to the crowd that the dude who
just told you that climate change isn't
real is Exxon mobil's guy that is a
relevant point to make now again you
could say that's got nothing to do with
the science around climate change but it
is it does deserve greater scrutiny and
the third one I talk about is the two
quo Quay uh you too the hypocrisy
argument which is one I deploy a lot
with politicians as an interviewer
politician a comes on the show and says
do this and you say but you don't do it
uh classic example Republicans who say
abortion
and all abortions while they secretly
pay a mistress to have an abortion yeah
now you could say technically that is
irrelevant to the substance of the
argument of abortion whether the fetus
has a right to life whether the fetus
feel fit is irrelevant right that's the
substance I agree but it is relevant in
an argument to be able to say to someone
if you can't adhere to the principles
you claim to stand for what does that
say about your principles so what I say
in this situation is Judge the moment
judge the relevance if you're talking
about covid with a doctor and the doctor
is saying trust me you don't need a
vaccine but that doctor has been
discredited in multiple studies all
their predictions have been wrong then
of course you should point that out if
the if the if the person you're up
against is making a pro homonym argument
trust me I'm a doctor trust me I'm a
general trust me I'm an economist it is
your obligation as someone interviewing
them debating them you know engaging
with them to say well how's your record
on this stuff it's pretty bad and people
get upset on my show when I bring up
their record but you know that's life
and to know the record is crucial and
one of your big old uh points all the
way through the book is you have to do
your homework you have to be prepared uh
bearing both of those things in mind
media's insistence on doing the homework
and on um the legitimacy sometimes of
taking down the credibility of an
interlocutor by reminding them of their
record I want you to have a look at this
clip from an intelligent Square debate
in fact
um about uh Saudi Arabia and its human
rights record this was uh media tangling
with Mamoon fandu is a pro Saudi writer
and commentator
let me just make one very quick point to
my moon moment I've got to say this you
talk about Islam and moduity and the
Christian Science monitor published a
piece in the 1990s saying the Egyptian
bow down to saudi-style Islam as a
student I saw fundamentally students go
to Saudi Arabia come back and distribute
books saudi-style fundamentalism
unnerves Egyptians Saudi influence must
be curb the author of that piece was one
Mamoon fandi that's true that's true
that's true
[Applause]
I'm still I'm still I'm still to my
point I'm still to my point that uh you
know influencing young and so on through
money and other things is is really
should be curbed however I have to
remind you that there is a functional
bow to a Saudis
ladies and gentlemen
I mean in a case like that
um he had nowhere left to go after that
once you I mean there's no there's no
more exhilarating line to deploy in an
argument debate or interview then your
words Mamoon your words and people get
very upset I've noticed this I've had
guests get very upset with me during
interviews after interviews
um I believe one of my former producers
Al jazer English is here tonight whose
job was to walk guests out of the studio
after I'd finished an interview with
them so I have props to Ryan Coles who I
believe is here tonight uh Who had who
had that unenviable task because people
get very annoyed that's a gotcha
question you hear that a lot Jonathan in
our in our line of work it's a gotcha
question and I again I push back against
that nothing wrong with a gotcha
question yes I'm trying to get you I'm
going to hold you to account yeah and
they're your words if you have a problem
with your words maybe you shouldn't have
said them but the point I was going to
go on to make was the that was six or
seven clicks deep yes on Google you say
in the book that people too often go for
the first page of Google yes and they
give up but you could be ages to find
that quote Yeah I don't I dug deep to
find this guy had a backlog of dozens of
Articles and books going about 20 years
but when you find that gold moment or
when a researcher of mine offer on a
show finds it it's one of those it's one
of those Eureka moments and it happened
with Eric prince and a famous clip as
well where we found a press release
showing that he was working in xinjiang
Province and it was a great moment when
we just displayed that it was partly
because the research I think it Googled
for the letters PDF which actually
expanded the research which is a very
very good tip and one I have already
stolen and myself it's very weird to sit
under a huge head of yourself yeah
it's yeah no I agree
um you um
describing the book The the thing of
conceding a point the other person has
made and you say it's a judo move right
and it stopped me reading it that okay
but you sometimes can see the point
because the other person might actually
be right yes and I'm thinking of your
wife's observation that you're not such
a great listener and I'm thinking well
maybe that's part of the problem if you
think acknowledging the other person
might be right is a judo move in other
words another way to actually get them
down on the floor and on the mat rather
than a genuine concession but it could
be both Jonathan well well I was going
to just come on to was to say is there
perhaps a difference between winning
every argument which is what your your
book is about and actually getting to
the truth of an issue and learning
what's right and do you think perhaps
professionally because you're so good at
it have you put sort of winning ahead of
learning it's a great question and it's
one of the ones that goes to the core of
the book and the title the title is very
provocative when I first put the cover
up on social media that was the response
from kind of 20 of people was like but
why would you want to win every argument
you shouldn't you should want to learn
and I get that and I understand that and
I think there is huge value in finding
common ground and learning new things
and negotiating a middle ground
to the people who want to do that I say
buy someone else's books I am
unashamedly saying that there are
hundreds of books out there on
negotiation and compromise and
persuasion this is not that book this is
a book that is going to teach you
unashamedly unapologetically how to win
and in my defense I would say this look
there are situations where you might
want to lose but I think we downplay how
many situations where you have to win
people treat argument like it's a choice
I was doing a today program interview
this morning and Michelle Nissan made
the point she said you know I wonder do
we should we want to win these arguments
in a polarized time don't some people
want to stay away from it and it's a
great question but we actually live in a
world where right now it's very hard to
avoid some argument you shouldn't want
to avoid some arguments some arguments
you have to win and the examples I give
of that for example if you are a
prosecutor in court trying to convict a
murderer you don't want to meet that
murderer halfway and kind of hear you
know you want to make sure the 12 jurors
put this guy who you believe is a threat
to society behind us if you're going for
a job interview which I consider a form
of argument you're making for yourself
you're trying to sell yourself you might
think to yourself you know what if I
listen to these guys maybe I'll realize
that I'm not the best person for this
job maybe the guy behind me should get
the job no of course not you're going to
get the job you're going to use whatever
tools that I give you to get that job
because you need that job you need the
income your family needs it etc etc so I
take your point I'm not disputing the
fact that in some areas you want to do
that I'm just saying that's not what my
book's about yeah and I'm not
apologizing for that but just on the
concession point I do believe you can do
both I do believe that you can make a
strategic concession what the Greek
school syncarice is what you're talking
about where you say your back's against
the wall the other person's made a great
Point too often we double down we say no
I will not concede I say in the book
concede just say great you got me I
didn't I didn't think at that point
hold on did you think of this point can
I come back with a stronger point which
is a very cynical and self-serving move
it's a strategic move but I don't see it
white either or while doing that it
doesn't have to be a dishonest move it
can be a genuine concession that I just
didn't see that point and actually
interestingly you and I were having a
conversation yesterday
about Gary lineker and you made some
interesting points that completely
undermined stuff I'd been saying on TV
for three days
I said that's a fair point now if we
were doing that on TV had we been on a
panel and you've done that I wouldn't
have disputed it I would have said yeah
that's a good point Johnny wait and then
moved somewhere else because thank you
for the concession
um
I didn't think that was coming but the
uh here's what I in a way to push it
further that I would go for and that is
somebody who was a brilliant debater I
mean in a way the sort of has had the
reputation for debate that I think you
now have which and the personal thing of
is Christopher Hitchens and he was such
a brilliant debater that those who heard
him would have been persuaded 20 years
ago you mentioned it to support the Iraq
War
but he was he was brilliant but he was
also wrong and he had all the skills
that you're recommending he won the
argument but it actually wasn't a good
outcome yeah and so what I suppose again
I'm saying that you're right people can
buy another book but you've given your
energies to a project that actually
doesn't necessarily get us to good
outcomes it
comes because it depends on how you use
the tools I'm not responsible for how
people use the tools I'm putting the
tools out there in fact I would argue
that it's because of 2003. let's take
Iraq as a good example in 2003
the people who made the pro-war
arguments people like Christopher
Hitchens Tony Blair obviously not George
W bush but more eloquent they were
people making the case
and it was the anti-war side good enough
I mean there's a separate debate about
did the media platform them enough Etc
but it's an interesting argument because
I one of the reasons I wrote the book is
not just because I have an abstract
desire about winning it's because I
believe that the things I believe in are
losing good because people are not
making the case well enough so I would
argue that the the bad guys or the
people I disagree with that you're
mentioning they're already winning
they're already using some of these
techniques Trump is already a master of
appealing to emotion he's a master of ad
hominem attack he's a master of kind of
uh you know using humor you know in his
own dark way and I'm saying to people on
the left progressives liberals the labor
party the Democratic party you need to
learn some of these things going back to
Aristotle you need to absorb some of
these lessons about human beings and how
they're persuaded so yes you can use
them in a bad way but uh you know I will
just wash my hands of that and say it's
not my problem yeah
um good let's have another let's look at
another bit you mentioned there the the
uh
defect on the left many of the people
you'd agree with is that they are often
they underestimate the importance of
emotion in an argument and you just said
just there that Donald Trump is rather
good at seeing the horribly cynical and
dark way but yes and that actually it's
one of the things particularly in the
United States I think where the left
Democrats are often incredibly robotic
and analytic and factual while the
writer much better on getting appealing
to the gut rather than the other sort of
adding machine in your head uh I think
you
um are are very aware of that and just
before we play the clip to you is a
debate um an emotional exercise or an
intellectual exercise most I know you
can say both which one it matters most I
will say both but it's not about what
matters most it's about the idea of what
is the most effective way of getting so
I say in the book the best vehicle for
logos for rational argument is pathos is
the emotional appeal emotion is what
gets you through the door it's what
opens up the other person's mind but
once you're through the door what do you
do that's when you deploy your facts and
figures so let's say you look at this
clip then this is from another of the
same actually it's an intelligent
squared debate this is Media stands
opening speech
ladies and gentlemen good evening I
stand before you tonight to make the
case for the motion and as I do a number
of names and faces flash through my mind
people who are counting on me and on you
tonight
to speak for them in this debate to give
them a voice tonight with your votes
for example a young women's rights
activist who was jailed in 2014 for
trying to drive her car in Saudi Arabia
upon her release from prison she went to
live in the UAE where last March she was
grabbed on the side of the freeway put
in cuffs thrown on a private jet and
taken back to Saudi Arabia against her
will today aged just 29 years old she
sits behind bars for the temerity of
asking for women to have the right to
drive
Lou Jane according to her sister as we
speak tonight is being held in solitary
confinement where she's been beaten
waterboarded
electrocuted sexually harassed and
threatened with rape and murder
you went home
um but it's the important point was you
went through this group of people I
think it culminated in Jamal khashoggi
um which was uh you were appealing there
to the heart but as you said it's in
order to open the door yeah so I had if
you watched the whole speeches on
YouTube I had a whole bunch of arguments
about why the West should cut ties with
Saudi Arabia which were about
geopolitics which were about the arms
trade which were about human rights
abuses but you can't open with his
Clause 4 of the UN Declaration on human
rights right that is the problem with a
lot of people as we say on the left in
the labor party on the Democratic party
it's always let me convince you by
giving you one more statistic one more
Fact one more figure one more Pew poll
one more peer-reviewed paper that's not
how people get convinced and I say in
the book opening romance you want to
grab people's attention you want to grab
them here not just here and the best way
to do that is to tell a story
storytelling is the the number one
mechanism for persuasion for convincing
people for connecting with people so
that the audience can identify with you
see something in common with you bond
with especially a personal story either
your own story or someone around you or
the story of someone they can identify
with so I told a bunch of real life
stories for at least three to four
minutes at the top of that speech one
after another before I got to any kind
of facts figures data or even my actual
argument because I just want to get the
audience in the right mood I want them
to understand what's at stake I want
them to feel something here so given
what you just said there about it don't
go for one more Fact one more a
surprising tip in your book is that you
say on homework
quantity not quality
no I say in the context of brainstorming
okay quantity now I say when you when
you're sitting down to come up with an
idea for a speech like that like how do
I come up with a speech like that I try
and give people insights into how do I
construct speeches how do I construct
interviews which I spend a lot of time
on what I say in the book is that if you
go I think it's Alex Osborne is the
founder of brainstorming back in the
1950s and he and his Protege came up we
decided brainstorming is about quantity
not quality the idea is to put as many
ideas on the page throw as many things
against the wall see what sticks and if
stuff comes out that's bad no harm no
foul put it in the bin right you know it
doesn't cost you anything to come up
with a bunch of crazy ideas so I do the
same thing when I do interview questions
I I don't worry about quality to begin
with I put down on page everything that
I could possibly ask the person in front
of me from the irrelevant to the
irreverent and then I go all right well
MSNBC never let me ask this question oh
this one will get me fired this one's
slightly gratuitous this is a bit unfair
this one I can't back up factually and I
get rid of the ones that and then I
refine it down so when I talk about that
in that sense that's that's more the
where do you start your brainstorming
and research from yeah well look let's
see uh a third example because there's a
a whole series of questions that flow
from this it did uh you know it it went
viral at the time it got a lot of
attention you were interviewing
um the former National Security advisor
to Donald Trump John Bolton do you want
do we need to cue in what you were
talking about in this I think the clip
that they wanted to play is this is not
we talked about Iraq for a long time but
I wanted to talk about Northern Iraq so
I brought up his support for regime
change in Iran and I wondered whether it
was tied to the fact that he was giving
paid speeches to a group of nut cases
called the MEK this kind of cult anti-uh
anti-muller group that's run by some
weirdos and uh that was the context for
the questions okay let's see this clip
let me ask you this uh can I ask how
much of your antipathy and your
criticism towards Iran I know you've
been very critical of Iran over 15 years
of nearly up let me ask you this how
much of your antipathy towards Iran is
to do with geopolitics how much of is to
do with the fact that you've had a long
association with a group called The MEK
which was once a terrorist group banned
by the state department while you worked
there you don't mention it in your book
I looked in your book there's no mention
of the MEK I think you took tens of
thousands of dollars for several
speeches just wondering how much that
influences your policy on Iran you know
that I took tens of thousands of dollars
from speeches for speeches at liberal
universities in the United States uh
this is uh this is this is really about
as low as it gets the the fact is that
Hillary Clinton
perhaps someone you support book The MDK
off the U.S list of terrorist
organizations how about that I speak
what I she took it off in 2012. you were
speaking with them in 2010 when they
were still a banned group
yeah now look that that that you're
simply wrong on your facts on this I
know you were there in Paris in 2010
speaking at the MEK rally when there was
still a banned terrorist group according
to the state department
nobody buys my opinion and you can
ignore that if you want I'm very
comfortable I have never said anything
other than what I believe and we are now
sir 20 minutes into this interview which
you said was for 50. I believe it's 15
minutes I've got a timer going off in my
ear so we have one last question before
you go and I appreciate your time
20 minutes go ahead and very last
question
[Applause]
so my question watching that is why on
Earth would anybody ever go on your show
thank you
that's the question I get asked by
friends of mine I say don't jinx it as
we Muslims say don't nazare me don't
give me evil eye I need to put food on
the table I need guests to come on my
show but it is it's a question a lot of
people ask um when I did Eric Prince a
lot of people asked why did Eric Prince
come on your show and I have to explain
to you Eric Prince is the former CEO of
Blackwater mercenary company it's
probably one of the most viral
interviews I've ever done it actually
got ended up with him getting referred
to the Department of Justice for a
criminal investigation for alleged
perjury because I called him out for uh
contradictions in his testimony and
people said afterwards Eric Prince this
Republican Trump supporting mercenary
why would he come on your show and I I
said I don't know
if I was Eric Prince I wouldn't have
come on my show but I'm glad he did
thank you Eric Prince helped my career a
lot
um I don't know why people come on the
show there's a mixture of reasons I can
only speculate some people like John
Bolton they just enjoy a row Bolton's
been debating since Yale University
they're very Uber confident in their own
abilities and I respect that that's good
let's let's do it I like people you know
who want to have a good argument in good
faith
um some people are ignorant they don't
do their homework they don't know
anything about the show when they turn
up I did a and some colleagues of mine
from Al Jazeera English here tonight I
did an interview with a senior
government official from a country I
won't name
who came on a show I did and as they sat
in I could see them and that was a
remote interview and I heard them say to
an aide what is this show who's this
host I was like you really should have
asked that days ago before you turned up
to do the engine and surprise surprise
that government then complained to Al
jazeer in the Quran afterwards so
ignorance arrogance some people are just
on a book tour so they sit down for any
interviews
um it's become harder as I've become
slightly more well-known in the US being
at altitude English gave me a certain
anonymity uh in an American audience at
least but yes it's become much more
difficult it's also become more
difficult Johnny because the people I
really want to interview some of these
kind of right-wing crazies are so crazy
I don't actually want to put them on my
show there's a chapter that's not in the
book which is when do you not have an
argument when do you walk away from an
argument and I you know I'll interview
John Bolton as repulsive as I find his
politics because I I know that he
believes what he's saying I don't think
he pretends to support the Iraq War he
genuinely believes that was he thinks it
was the right thing to do he doesn't
think he did anything wrong and he's
clearly an intelligent person even if I
don't like him but would I have like a
Marjorie Taylor green on my show no
because I just election deniers no
climate change denies no Holocaust
deniers no I'm not going to argue
reality I'm not going to argue Up Is
Down black is white hot it's cold that
stuff I won't do but people who are
willing to come on in good faith even if
they haven't done their homework about
me yeah bring it but as you said more
and more people are doing their homework
and people will you know the show has a
reputation yeah I'm wondering if if in a
way firstly they're going to shy away
from coming on your show but also
whether
that one of the sadnesses of the current
polarized state of particularly American
life but I think it maybe exists in
other places is that the kind of old
school debate that you embody and that
you relish is happening more and more
rarely yeah so that actually people are
in their silos speaking only to their
political family yes
um and very rarely are they colliding
with the opposite camp and in a way well
it's you know it's been great for you
but you know you're part of that because
you're on MSNBC most of the guests on
the MSNBC are not jumbled yeah they're
actual Democrats interviewing other
Democrats liberals interviewing other
liberals it's all very cozy and your
show stands out something of an
exception but do you think it is a sort
of endangered form and that the network
you work for is part of the problem so
it's definitely an endangered form and I
but I don't think the part of the
network is I'm not specific because I'm
employed and they pay my bills but
genuinely I I kind of I kind of get
I get frustrated with this msnbc's
liberal foxes conservative cables
divided America America is divided for
many many reasons well beyond cable news
and it's a symptom not a cause it's a
symptom but also I don't hide the fact
that I do an opinion show and I'm on a
network that's considered liberal Earth
that's very different to Fox Fox is not
a News Network FOX is a propaganda organ
and you don't have to take my word for
it just check out the leaked emails and
depositions from the fox Dominion case
that's going on right now where Rupert
Murdoch admits under oath that his hosts
were lying and they endorsed a big lion
maybe they shouldn't have where you know
Fox hosts are texting each other saying
well Trump's lawyers are crazy and this
stuff is mad and our viewers they
believe this stuff you know I tell
people you can loathe everything I say
on my show but I guarantee you I say the
same thing in private I don't see
something different to my audience and
then me and Rachel Maddow and Chris
Hayes don't text each other saying we
actually love Donald Trump Joe Biden
actually lost the election it doesn't
happen so on a fundamental factual basis
Fox is not news msnbc's news look I
would like to have more more people from
do I hate soggy consensus I would like
to have more people to disagree with but
again as I say if part of the political
Spectrum has been taken over by grifters
con men gas sliders people who don't
believe in stuff then I don't know where
to go to find good faith argument I try
we look for it but it's getting it is
getting harder and harder and it's
depressing one of the reasons I wrote
the book is to try and push back against
that to say these people are degrading
our public discourse our Public Square
there is a way to do it better history
teaches us that my own career teaches us
that Common Sense teachers as that so it
is a kind of Call to Arms in a sense a
lot of people when they move countries
British people who then live abroad so
they never feel more British than when
they are in the new country abroad right
interesting and I'm wondering if for you
that's happened in this very particular
way which is it seems to be what you're
doing on American television is bringing
the techniques that are actually quite
normal of British political interviewing
that Robin day much you know before your
time but Jeremy Paxman John Humphries
Andrew Neal that's just what they do
and I you know as you know I've lived in
Washington a while I worked there there
was an absence of that then too and I
can completely see why you're sort of
revolutionary there you shake things up
because you're the first person they've
had doing it
what is going on in American culture do
you think that explains why they have
this much less confrontational more
polite media than Britain given the fact
that actually people think of this
country as being the country it's it's
conflict of us and more polite so what's
that about yeah it's something I've
talked about for the last eight nine
years since I've been there I talked
about it on Seth Meyers late night
comedy show I've talked about it
wherever I could talk about people ask
the same question what's the difference
with the British media in the US mean
look I'm a big critic of the British
press as you know there's many problems
with our media but when it comes to TV
interviews we do do it better than the
US and most other countries I grew up
watching Paxman idolizing Paxman loving
what he did
um and I on the book tour in America I
brought up the Paxman story in front of
multiple audiences and said there was a
guy on British TV go on YouTube he once
asked our version of the Attorney
General the same question 13 times if
you remember the famous 1994 Michael
Howard interview that Paxman did and
eyes bulge there they can never imagine
American interview doing that would just
be seen as rude crossing a line and it
is interesting the country that is the
Revolutionary country the country that
threw off the monarchy threw off
unbridled executive power threw off
British tradition is now the country
that's kind of suffocated by tradition
conventions norms and when you try and
push against those people get very upset
I do think it is a cultural thing as
well and that we we we're just Ruder
aren't we I mean let's be honest like
you know we don't we don't you know what
a bigger cultural shot for me than
American television when I went there is
just the basics of going to get
groceries or going to the store like I
don't need to say have a nice day to
everyone every day I don't need to chat
to the person on the Metro like I'm from
the London Underground you look down
persons being stabbed next to you carry
on really your Kindle like that is where
I that's that you know uh so so it is I
think we're a bit more in your face
we're less concerned about kind of play
it is a complete inversion in a way that
people don't realize when the president
walks in the room the Press will stand
up in the U.S and that's only because
he's the head of state not just the head
of government but it's not just the
president Senators Congress isn't it
weird in America they keep their titles
just the mind-boggling secretary Clinton
mayor Giuliani mayor of what your back
Garden you haven't been mayor for 15
years but they just keep it like you
keep dukes and Lords it's very very odd
it's like their own aristocracy and I
wish we could get rid of a lot of that
because that would help a lot with
interviews also I do think there's a
separate problem which are flicks
Britain and America which is you know
try not I try not to socialize too much
with people in power you know if you're
hanging out with people and dining and
whining and meeting with people in power
it's very hard then to do a tough
interview the following morning yeah you
describe a moment in the book on being
when you've been on question time and
you I mean the book is you know you're
not hesitant to blow your own trumpet in
the book you always tell us which Clips
went viral how many uh Clips it how many
retweets you get Etc if you're not gonna
Bang Your Own Drum who is who will so in
one of these moments you say that David
dimbleby asks comes up to you after
you've just astonished the audience with
your Brilliance and he comes up to you
and says how come you know so much she
says uh and he's a really surprised here
how much homework you've done you tell
him and it just struck me that that
might be a kind of child of immigrants
thing that if you are uh David dimbleby
if you're cool you know if you're cool
David dimbleby you just Breeze onto the
question time and you don't need to talk
but if you because you feel kind of Born
to it and entitled to it but if you're
called Maddie Hassan my word you better
be to coin a phrase twice as good as
everyone else on that panel and do much
more home and get half as much back as
the phrase goes I think you're 100 right
that is that is a lot of it and the
chapters and doing your homework and
preparation definitely flow from being
the child of Indian immigrants and now
being you know my wife and I both of
Indian origin and we do that to our kids
too you know my daughter will say I've
got homework but it's optional there's
no option alone you do it all tonight
you know TV till the optional stuff's
done what do you mean optional none of
the other kids don't do it doesn't
matter yeah so we are very much of that
school and that comes from both of our
parents
um and yeah I think I think being over
prepared is partly the legacy of the
kind of hard work of immigrants who are
trying to fit in it's also the legacy of
being held to a different standard
there's a lot of white privilege
involved with people on question time
um you know I was with baroness Varsity
on Saturday in Bradford doing an event
like this and she she and I were talking
about how we both spent a lot of time on
the footnotes of the book I spent ages
trying to get this right still fingers
and toes across that I covered
everything sourced everything really
wanted to get it right and she made the
point I won't take the name she named a
conservative politician a white man
whose book came out at the same time as
hers had no footnotes in it right and
she went over to and she said that's
what white privilege looks like she had
hundreds of footnotes he didn't feel the
need he had to cite anything yeah
because he's who he is yeah so he
thought that would be Authority enough
that would be Authority enough and
question time I think with the great
respect to David didn't will be retired
man that he is I think that's an
approach you know who's this young Brown
outspoken kid and had seen no more than
the cabinet ministers to my left because
I did my homework when I did question
time I would block out two to three days
of the week I would read everything and
the story in the book that I talk about
it was about something I knew nothing
about it was about the sports
Personality of the Year award it was a
big debate about why weren't there any
women on the shortlist and I'd gone
through and checked like how the
Manchester Evening News had voted in
that way and you know it pays off
there's great return When you put in the
work the return is there and I and I
tell that story because I want to show
people that the return is there it's
worth doing the work that it's a value
add and yes to bang my own drum yeah
sure good for
well I'm going to stay with that I mean
about being a Muslim in America and on
the one hand
it's the land of religious Faith much
more than here it's the you know houses
of worship per 100 people more than any
other country in the industrialized
World on the one hand uh on the other
hand it's a country where a man could
propose a Muslim ban as he called it and
get elected president yeah so for you is
it easier or harder to be a Muslim in
America than it is to be a Muslim in
Britain it's a great question it's a
question I wrestled with for nearly a
decade now and I guess my art again to
go back to what I said right at the
start context matters I guess it depends
when and where I am you know am I am I
talking as a Muslim in the media am I
talking as a Muslim father of two kids
trying to bring up their kids in school
it all depends on where you are like my
answer changes depending on the year the
time right now I would say having come
back to the UK and seen what's going on
in the UK and seeing some of the debates
you recently had on prevent in
particular I would say it's probably
worse to be a Muslim in the UK right now
I probably wouldn't have said that in
2016 2017 2015. but I think the US is in
a much better place you talked about the
Muslim ban obviously the man who pitched
that Muslim ban uh then saw thousands of
people turn up at airports to resist
that Muslim ban and then was voted out
of office and then had that Muslim ban
revoked and I so I think we are in a
different place in the United States
right now
um
again you mentioned Christianity and
church Faith I mean that is on the plus
column although white Christian events I
mentioned well it's plus and minus white
Christian evangelicals tend to be the
most islamophobic people sadly
um out of mainly out of ignorance but
also out of fear and paranoia but on the
other hand it is a land that still
respects faith in a way that the UK and
parts of Europe certainly don't I'm much
I'm much more comfortable about
expressing my faith uh as a journalist
in the US and I don't know how you feel
about this but also being a person of
Faith but you know I think the British
secular media is probably more
antipathetic more hostile towards faith
in general not just and I don't mean
hostile isn't like mean but more like
what is this that's weird anything to do
with God and religion you practice the
number of people in the UK who would be
shocked over the years right from my
Oxford days to my media days that I
actually practice you actually thought
you don't drink I get less of that in
the United States because there are more
people of all Faith practicing so I
think think that is a cover that you do
get there yeah no that's exactly what I
meant is a country that just has the
language of or the vocabulary of faith
and I think one the last time you and I
did one of these or perhaps the first
time we did one of these face race
conversations we end up we ended up
trading tips on fasting as the Jew and
the Muslims coming up in the room you're
joining us Johnny my one is not till the
not till September your one's like one
day it's 25 hours it's unbroken come on
it's 25 it does you you basically cram
it all into one we do we spread it out
although although the classic question
every Muslim in the room if how many
Muslims I don't know when you're a kid
do you always hear us
fasting for 30 days don't eat for no
every day from Sunrise
um just one quick point though one last
thing on the Christian thing is is
what's what's funny on the on the
Christian element is that it is it is
the kind of land of faith and you are
able to talk about faith and you are
able to kind of uh have the language of
Christianity and yet
it is depressing to see what's happened
with evangelicals and their shift to the
right these are a group of people who
claim to not like Muslims Jews whatever
because they're not people of the Bible
but their favorite politician is the
most unchristian man in the history of
mankind Donald J Trump Thrice married
twice adulterer failed casino owner Man
Who Can't identify one verse of the
Bible he is their hero he is their
golden calf yeah so that is deeply
depressing to see what's happening they
have this whole theological argument
that he's like Cyrus yes
the instrument of God now I should have
been saying for those of you who are
watching uh online watching the live
stream that you should be submitting
your questions in the box underneath the
screen so do that here but we've got
plenty of questions and scope for
questions
um in the room and I'm sure we'll get
some of your online questions uh coming
to us what were you about to say one
last quick thing on one last question
point which is another reason why it's
interesting America yeah I live in a
country
where the craziest religious people
aren't Muslims which is a huge Advantage
I can tell you having lived in a country
where Muslims like I'll be honest with
the greatest respect to my British
Muslim Brethren we've done some crazy
stuff in this country and people in our
community have done some crazy stuff in
the U.S like it's Muslims forgive the
phrase hold my beer it's our Christian
cousins who are interacting at the
capital so I know I had ilhan Omar on my
show the other day and she and I had a
conversation about terrorism it was two
Muslims on Prime Time MSNBC talking
about terrorism that wasn't Muslim
terrorism right that was a weird Moment
For Me Through the Looking Glass and
were you urging the mainstream Christian
Community to denounce I do I do I can't
help but make that snarky Point always
um very very good why don't we see if we
can take some questions
foreign